a hero's just someone who doesn't give
up your dad said that
he was right
now it's your turn go be a hero miles
okay let's do this
[Music]
uh i ready the web shooters are a little
tight
get used to it just try to keep up
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new spider-man ps5
miles morales video we found out a bunch
more details bunch more easter eggs so
this is going to be a bigger video
about that if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos
i will do a giveaway for copies of the
game when the pre-orders
start so i'll explain that a little bit
more at the end of the video but what
happened this morning
is the insomniac came out and clarified
what's going on with the story of the
game because people were confused if you
look
in your timeline you might see people
calling it spider-man 2. like is this
meant to be the sequel to spider-man ps4
is this meant to be dlc is this a whole
different game what's going on there was
a lot of confusion after the trailer
dropped yesterday
so this morning insomniac clarified that
this is meant to be a whole game by
itself like a big self-contained story
for miles morales
but it's not meant to be the direct
sequel to spider-man ps4 that'll be a
completely different game that'll come
out at some point in the future so maybe
another year or two before we see
anything about that
it takes a long time to make those much
bigger games so it sounds like the miles
morales game is going to be a little bit
smaller but i'll explain the story as we
go along
here and talk about the easter eggs they
likened it to uncharted lost legacy if
you're a big video game player that's
not a direct sequel to the uncharted
series it's just like a side game with a
bunch of extra stuff going on that they
can justify
charging you 60 dollars to buy so that's
why during this spider-man miles morales
game they'll probably only loosely
reference
some of the bigger peter parker
spider-man ps4 hanging plot threads and
post-credit scenes like the norman
osborne green goblin stuff that they're
setting up
the harry osborn venom stuff that
they're setting up a lot of the mary
jane
spider-man scenes at the end there
especially that stanley cameo scene with
the two of them i don't know if mary
jane is going to be involved in this
game at all
but it's mostly all just meant to
continue the story that they tease for
miles morales in the first game in the
extra tag scenes during the expansions
so the trailer begins with the peter
parker voice over it's unclear how much
time has gone by
since that silver linings spider-man ps4
post credit scene
but it sounds like peter is not doing so
hot like i don't think that he's dying
here it doesn't mean that he's dead
in this part of the game and that's why
this is miles's game and he's not
involved with it in a big way
but the jaden and kid cudi song that
plays on the trailer
on my own implies that peter won't be
helping him out with the main
storyline he'll have to be in at least a
couple big cut scenes to set things up
at the beginning and maybe the ending to
bring things back around and help
set up an actual spider-man ps5 sequel
game like they'll have some sort of tag
scene that will push into the sequel
but i'm sure just like there were
expansions for the first spider-man ps4
game there'll be at least one or two
expansions for this miles morales game
with more of his storyline
so the story miles morales game picks up
after the spider-man ps4 silver linings
post-credit scene where peter has
started to teach miles finally how to
web sling
and they go full spider-man into the
spider-verse this scene almost looks
like it was ripped directly out of that
too
this version of miles morales got the
spider bite during the first game from
one of the special oscorp spiders that
escaped
while he was working at the shelters and
by the end of the game in one of the
post-credits scenes he reveals to peter
that he has spider-man abilities now too
i think it's i think it's better that i
just um
it's pretty weird right
[Music]
not that weird they don't really get
into all his special abilities all the
different ones that he has from the
comics during the first game or even in
any of the post-credits scenes just
because they're basically setting this
up like hey i have abilities now
could i become your protege teach me how
to be spider-man but he does
have a lot of special abilities that you
see during the trailer because they
didn't want him to be an exact copy of
peter parker when he debuted in the
comics so they wanted to make some of
his spider-man abilities seem completely
different from peter parker's
you see a lot of them during the trailer
primarily his venom blast which looks
kind of like the speed force lightning
they color it differently from the venom
blast in spider-man into the spider
verse it's kind of blue during that
they also show off his other big special
move his stealth ability that allows him
to go virtually invisible just blending
in with his surroundings
in fact there's even a shot in the
trailer here where he's using both
abilities at the same time
he goes full stealth when he's jumping
this villain then mid-air while he's
still cloaked he
activates his venom blast and punches
the crap out of them
there were a lot of you that asked about
brooklyn because that's where miles is
from in the comics it's heavily featured
during spider-man into the spider-verse
most of the places you see him web
slinging and fighting villains in the
trailer here are in brooklyn
like especially him walking around the
city streets here i'm sure he won't only
be in brooklyn during the game though
some of these scenes seem like they're
taking place around grand central
station so i'm sure he'll go all over
the city
it's not really clear where miles is
going to get his black spider-man suit
from because he's wearing it in this
trailer here
but it's clear that there's been some
sort of time jump since that silver
linings post credit scene so at some
point he created the suit
during spider-man into the spider-verse
aunt may lets him have ultimate peter
parker's classic spider-man suit and he
just spray paints it black
then spray paints the red logo on top in
the comics he actually gets his first
spider-man costume from his friend genki
genki had a spider-man halloween costume
from the previous year and when he
learned miles's secret he offered it to
him hey if you're gonna go be spider-man
wear a spider-man costume
so he wore it during some of his
original fights but then decided that
because
peter had died and people were confused
about spider-man maybe coming back to
life he decided that wearing the red
classic colors was in bad
taste so that eventually inspired him to
create his trademark black suit that you
see in all the comics
they kind of did an easter egg for that
during spider-man into the spider-verse
so he goes and there's a big stanley
post credit scene because he's the guy
that sells
miles that spider-man costume so he's
wearing the halloween costume for part
of the trailer
until eventually he gets his own costume
towards the end
there was a special intro scene for the
first spider-man ps4 game where peter
parker is making the new white logo
costume
so i'm sure there's going to be some
similar scene early on in the miles
morales game where he makes his black
costume based on one of peter parker's
old costumes
all the purple tech that the villains
he's fighting are using seem kind of
similar to some of the sable tech but
this one person with the purple jet
trails behind his boots he's chasing
after
seems right out of spider-man into the
spider-verse there was a scene just like
this in that movie
so this might be the prowler his uncle
aaron davis
he's one of his main villains so why
wouldn't he be in the miles morales game
the other villains that he's fighting
though seem a little bit different but
they all seem like they're using some
version of black market sable tech
it's hard to tell who some of them
exactly are but because this is all
about miles's story i'm assuming a lot
of them will be
core miles morales villains from the
comics the only boss fight here in the
trailer that seems a little different is
when he's fighting this guy
in the red mech suit midair omega red is
one of the only big
red mech suit wearing villains that i
can think of that's fought miles in the
comics but this is
probably going to be somebody different
post all your theories about who you
think some of these villains are is kind
of hard to tell without getting more of
a story trailer
but because the game is a launch title
for the ps5 later this year we'll get a
bigger story trailer with more details
on who the villains are
what'll probably happen too is when they
start taking pre-orders for the game
that's when they'll probably drop that
next big trailer usually that's what
happens
so if you weren't sure this is going to
be a playstation exclusive game
i don't know if they're going to make
the game playable on ps4
because the whole idea is that sony
wants you to buy a ps5
so we'll see how mean they are until
sony comes out and makes an official
statement or insomniac or someone
just assume that it's only going to be
playable on ps5
but that's not confirmed yet and what'll
happen is when they open pre-orders and
drop that next big story trailer
that's when i'll probably start doing
the giveaways for copies of the game but
i can't really do that until they start
taking pre-orders so as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you'll see
those videos when i post them
there'll also be a big comic con
happening this summer but it'll be
virtual online there'll be special
panels so i'm expecting marvel to drop a
couple of their big trailers at some
point during that week
everyone post all your reactions and
your big questions in the comments below
click here for my new spider-man into
the spider-verse 2 teaser trailer video
and easter eggs
and click here for my brand new venom 2
trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight